So here is the answer, I feed in all the missing
values for you. And let’s try to check a few.
For example, let’s take the elements related to
X1. We move from X0 to X1 which added one
of the remainder indiscernible . We move
from X1 to X2, which added another one, so
we have two, but we also had one observation
in X1, we incremented by two because of the
measurement string, 0.5. One over that is 2
so when we added the measurement end up
with 4. Let’s pick this off tagging element over
here. This was only affected when moving from
X1 to X2 and it was a minus 1. This element
over here was affected when we sensed L1 from
X1 and again the off tagging element is
negative. So we added minus 2 over here.
It’s quite involved, as you can see. Let’s
take a number on the right side, the minus 2
over here. This is adding up a re-contribution
to X2. The first one occurred when we moved
into X2 from X1 at which point we added two
. But in X2 we also measure length by L1 with
a measurement value of two. We have to multiply
that for a two to arrive at four and subtract it,
so we have made minus four, you get
the minus two. If you work out at all these
examples, using the math we explained in class
and working in the effective measurements get
a default effect of two for every value you add,
you arrive at exactly this matrix over
here. I hope you got a good number
of numbers right that was not an easy task.